[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le centre de recherche en design c'est
avant tout déjà une aventure fabuleuse
c'est la rencontre de deux univers
l'univers de la recherche scientifique
dans des domaines qu'on appelle les
sciences dures et l'univers du design de
la création du ce triel dollar qui on
m'appellerait parfois les sciences
molles qui viennent se rejoindre pour
créer un centre où effectivement à faire
la recherche en commun en particulier
c'est de permettre aussi à cette
discipline du design de faire de la
recherche de porter des doctorants qui
vont faire des thèses et de permettre
effectivement d'avoir des réflexions sur
le monde futur de tous horizons et donc
c'est l'objectif de cette exposition ici
aujourd'hui que je vous présente c'est
de vous montrer les expéditions que
peuvent faire nos chercheurs aujourd'hui
sur ces territoires de la recherche
en rejoignant ses deux univers de la
recherche donc quoi de mieux que d'être
au sein de lever n'est ce magnifique
bâtiment ce qui est donc le bâtiment qui
accueille le centre de recherche en
design
les quoi de mieux que ce lieu pour vous
exposer aujourd'hui tous ces projets de
doctorants le design à sa place à
l'école normale supérieure de paris
saclay aux côtés des sciences de
l'ingénieur saisi il ya une proximité
évidente entre eux le design la création
industrielle c'est celle intitulée de
2,26 et les sciences de l'ingénieur qui
font la singularité de l'école normale
supérieure de paris saclay par rapport
aux autres écoles normales supérieures
l'intérêt principal de la création de ce
centre de recherche en design c'est la
recherche
on est ici sur le le site de paris
saclay sur la première université
française au classement de shanghai
s'est confirmée en 2021
et donc c'était faire du design au coeur
de ce site de l'université paris saclay
et c'est là qu'on va pouvoir interagir
avec les sociologues avec les
informaticiens
avec les sciences de l'ingénieur au
niveau de la recherche
[Musique]